l'hypnose médicale fait son entrée à
l'hôpital pour enfants de montréal
coralie en a fait l'expérience deux fois
je sais que ça va presque rien faire
avec
je traite c'est un peu pour aurait pu en
prendre un en trouver c'est avec une
histoire que la technologue spécialement
formé peu hypnotisé la petite fille de 9
ans pour qu elles ne ressentent pas de
douleur pendant l'installation d'un
cathéter et choisissent une thématique
de base et puis nous apprécions on brode
donc avec l'information qu'on a eu on a
appris comment utiliser les mots de
façon positive pour mettre le cerveau
dans une zone de confort
vous vous êtes assise pas loin derrière
ce qui est ce que vous entendez fils de
jah parvenant pas si vraiment les deux
grâce à l'imagination fertile de vicky
l'histoire reste lié à tout ce qui se
passe pendant l'intervention
par exemple un oiseau l'oiseau vient
voir l'enfant loiseau et sur son doigt
c'est le moment piqué je veux dire
peut-être se fassent sentir les petites
griffes de l'oiseau ou peut-être que non
donc je le suggère le cerveau aux
herbiers où il ya un oiseau sur mon
doigt c'est normal que je ressens
quelque chose même si c'est pas sur mon
doigt que la procédure se fait une
technologue est venu de france donné une
formation de cinq jours
le projet pilote a permis de constater
l'efficacité de l'hypnose lors de deux
procédures différentes pratiques et sur
80 patients âgés de 6 ans et plus et
divisés en deux groupes le groupe
contrôle sans hypnose en moyenne pour
tous les types d'examens confondues nous
ont coté à 5 points 4 sur 10 et le
groupe expérimental avec l'hypnose la
cote a été à un point quatre sur dix
alors une immense différence
on peut ainsi épargner aux enfants de la
douleur et les inconvénients de
l'anesthésié on peut pas demander mieux
finalement qui a dansé nation par
exemple notre en maths réveil sont pas
tout à fait bien fait plus l'on doit
attendre on étend du saut à des biopsies
qui ont été faites sous hypnose sans
sédation parce que ces types d'examens
l'eau se faisait avec sédation ou
parfois même avec anesthésie générale
quand on quitte le elle est contente
elle est l'atout long du chemin de
retour m racontez-nous rencontre son
rêve nous racontent qu'ils allaient
flatun lyon quelle volée sur un papillon
coralie qui revient à l'hôpital tous les
trois mois ne se passeraient plus de
l'hypnose ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal